herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie ich hoffe sie sind bei
bester gesundheit und phase doch mit
grippe auf dem sofa liegen was tun sie
greifen sie zu zwiebel wickel oder
ingwer oder vertrauen sie doch lieber
helfen soll das ja alles irgendwie oder
doch nicht spielt es eigentlich eine
rolle zu welchem heilmittel wir greifen
und was eigentlich ist ganzheitliche
medizin auf visite bei mir ist jetzt
dietrich grönemeyer ist arzt und
bestsellerautor und sein neuestes buch
heißt welt medizin auf dem weg zu einer
ganzheitlichen heilkunst herzlich
willkommen herr grönemeyer ja herr grüne
war ja hand aufs herz wie oft greifen zu
medikamenten
also wenn das richtig hart wirkt zum
beispiel hatte ich ein abszess an meinen
zähnen die sich mit spülung salbei
spülungen und auch teebaumöl nicht
gewirkt haben dann nämlich auch
medikamente musste dann sogar danach zum
zahnarzt
ich kann das nüchtern in den saal noch
gebaut hat nein das mache ich schon
also erst mal sanft versuchen und danach
kommt der harte stoff ja eigentlich
zwischen leicht und schwer ist
eigentlich immer so meine devise so
wenig wie möglich so viel wie gerade
nötig das fängt beim hausmittel an das
geht in der naturheilkunde
traditionellen heilweisen aber dann
genauso natürlich eine schulmedizin die
ja fantastisches in den westen im
letzten jahrhundert geschaffen hat
würden sie sich auch den freund da
trieben den blutegel ansetzen
ich würde es tun ich mag sie als
lebewesen die mir ein bisschen
unheimlich
aber in der in der behandlung
beispielsweise eine arthrose eine
kniegelenksarthrose ist zeigte professor
der universität essen-duisburg oder
michael sind von der charité in berlin
dass die zum teil besser wirken als
schmerzmittel und das finde ich schon
überzeugt die blutegel sind ja ein
beispiel das vorkommt in ihrem buch über
das sie wie sie schreiben eine der
ältesten heilmittel die es überhaupt
gibt wird das jahrhundert vor christus
schreiben sie datiert schon
die dokumentation über die wirkung der
blutegel und interessant fand ich das
ist ja eigentlich der speichel ist
dieser blutegel die die eu abgeben
genau gespeichert sind einfach blut
lösende elemente das heißt sie können
dann ganz schnell ganz schnell die haut
auflösen und an das blut geraten und
saugen blut und gleichzeitig ist es
sicherlich auch eine reflexion therapie
rund um das kniegelenk das wissen wir
schon aus der chinesischen medizin dass
der akupunkturpunkte legen und
gleichzeitig wirken sie auch mit
elementen schmerzstillend und kommen die
blutegel denn auch in ihrer klinik zum
einsatz sie haben ja selber eine große
knick kommen mit 20 ärzten wieder
arbeiten
genau wir haben eine erfahrene
heilpraktikerin die die blutegel auch
zwischendurch ansetzen aber immer gucken
wir was ist notwendig und wie kombiniert
man möglicherweise auch bei chronischen
schmerzen auf der einen seite
schulmedizinische arbeit ich arbeite mit
ganz kleinen instrumenten als mikro
therapeuten radiologe von hause aus hat
lange den lehrstuhl bis vor kurzem für
radiologie und mikrotherapie der
universität witten/herdecke geleitet und
dann gucken wir hilft die sonde die
jetzt gezielt schmerzmittel an die
bandscheibe beispielsweise bringt oder
hitzbleck oder muss man nicht noch
zusätzlich was machen das heißt sie
haben irgendwo noch so ein becken mit
blutegeln in der klinik 3 1 1 1 die
werden sie werden vom apotheker besorgt
da gibt es für uns und der apotheke hat
gibt's hier auch wieder zurück nein also
ganz gut sie haben die auch in der
apotheke gehabt das ist ein heilmittel
und das gehört in der apotheke und dort
müssen sie auch wie man damit umgehen
muss
haben sie selber schon gesagt sie sind
radiologe und das ist ja erst einmal
erstaunlich ein radiologe arbeitet mit
vielen apparaturen sie haben auch schon
gesagt sie betreiben diese mikrotechnik
und da geht es darum dass man eben mit
nadeln patienten behandelt zum beispiel
bandscheibenvorfällen aber auch
entfernung von tumoren machen sie auf
diese weise und der patient liegt ja
einen kernspintomographen oder in der
computertomografie das heißt es ist ein
bild gestütztes verfahren alles hoch
spezialisiert hochtechnisiert
gleichzeitig plädieren sie für die
ganzheitliche heilkunst dann hängt man
ja mal wie geht das zusammen
ja das sieht auch auf den ersten moment
ganz schlecht aus auf der anderen seite
bin ich groß geworden der sechsten
generation mittlerweile fast immer
zwischen schulmedizin und globuli also
eine tante von mir war
naturheilkundler in die andere war
schule medizinerin und da ging es
eigentlich immer darum wer hat recht
und das war mir damals schon zu wieder
zu hause wenn sich schwere bronchitis
hatte und münchen musste und dann die
beiden tanten sich in meiner gegenwart
darum klappten mehr gibt ist jetzt
richtig der naturheilkunde und der mit
den antibiotika und als radiologe sage
ich heute endlich in den körper rein
gucken kann
das habe ich damals gelernt weil ich
schon als kleines kind ständig männchen
gerät stand völlig erschüttert weil ich
dann dunkel stand ja meine eltern
dürften nicht mit rein ich fand das
fürchterlich aber heute sage ich wenn
ich ganz schnell untersuchen kann sehe
den ganzen körper sehe die bandscheiben
den tumor die gefäße die nerven wenn ich
glaube ich nicht daran nehme gewebe raus
wenn ich brauch oder injizieren
medikamente zur schmerz medikation oder
wo die bandscheibe so raus mit kleinen
instrumenten oder den wandel den tumor
das ist mikrotherapie und gleichzeitig
ist die naturheilkunde ganz nahe weil
der patient muss ja weiter betreut
werden hat
er muss wärme umschläge kriegen er muss
massiert werden er muss entspannen
das sind alles naturkundlich ansätze
tauchen wir mal ein bisschen einen in
diese heilkunst oder eben das was die
welt medizin nennen das ist der begriff
den sie geprägt haben der ihnen auch am
herzen liegt und dazu gehört zum
beispiel schauen wir nicht mühsam
drauflegen ayurveda und sie sagen die
these ist ganz klar wer heilt hat recht
erstmal ist doch so genau
jetzt kann man aber sagen na ja geht
natürlich herr grönemeyer schon warum
wir eigentlich ursächlich für die
heilung verantwortlich ist nehmen wir
mal an jemand macht einen entwickeln
dann sieht man noch drei tagen der ist
wieder genesen da kann man sich ja
fragen lag das jetzt am entwickeln oder
lag das daran dass der wegen des
entwicklers nicht zur arbeit gehen
konnte weil das stinkt ein bisschen also
blieb das schön zu hause im bett
jetzt waren jedoch wissen woran lag's
wirklich also ich gehe noch weiter also
ich erinnere mich an diese entwickeln
denn wenn ich branche bieten hatte krieg
dich immer eins entwickeln umgelegt und
sehe mich heute noch auf den armen
meines vaters als kleines kind durch den
horn getrag war es die körper erleben
wir haben meines vaters war es die nähe
was das entwickeln oder meine innere
heilungskräfte ich sag mal so erstmal
heißt der placebo ich mache aus einem
chemischen nichts ein biochemischer
vorgang
das ist doch schon mal interessant also
wenn wenn menschliche nähe dazu hilft
dass ich mich besser fühle dass ich
kräftiger werde dass ich vertrauen habe
ihn nicht selbst dann ist das ein
wunderbarer ansatz im psychosomatik der
psychosomatischen therapie das gilt für
alle ärzte und das war und therapeuten
das war in den alten traditionellen
heilweisen immer da wird nicht der
körper behandelt und der geist getrennt
sondern beides zusammen deswegen rede
ich auch vom körper geist und dann gibt
es die spezifischen sachen reflexzonen
therapie und körperoberfläche inhalation
des senfs ist antibakteriell und auch
beschrieben und auch wissenschaftlich
weiter erforscht und dann gibt es eben
noch
die den ansatz der aktivierte
selbstheilungskräfte ich glaube wir
müssen es nicht teilweise so auseinander
dividieren den subjekt und subjektivität
und objektivität gehört auf jeden fall
zusammen
das ist getrennt die frage was hat jetzt
wirklich geholfen die bettruhe oder der
entwickelt das ist für sie gar nicht
sinnvoll weil sie sagen würden das
gehört sowieso immer irgendwie zusammen
ich habe fieber gehört mal ins bett wenn
man schwer erkrankt ist der unterschied
ist gehört man ins bett
ja und dann muss man in all ihren em
titel hilft die branchenweit zu machen
das wissen werden wärme tut erst mal
weil man sich wohlfühlt wohl erfüllt und
wärme führt dazu dass die jahre flex
punkte die die masseure auch
beispielsweise therapieren eben
aktiviert werden also ist das wunderbare
kommen ja wenn das nicht hilft wird er
montiert ist und es droht eine lunge zu
da müssen antibiotika gegeben werden und
wieso gehört man bei fieber genau ins
bett ich kann ja auch paracetamol ihm
dann fühle ich mich wieder gut und kann
zur arbeit gehen
fieber ist ja eigentlich ein alarmsignal
dass es irgendwas im körper bestimmt und
fieber ist auch ein signal dass der
körper jetzt mit seinem gesamten
immunsystem gegen den virus gegen das
bakterium angeht was er der tolle
reaktion ist und diese reaktion heißt es
erstmal zu unterstützen aus meiner sicht
deswegen leicht anfang mit wadenwickeln
auch das habe ich gelernt wadenwickel
sind für mich im ersten moment kalt ist
eine wunderbar angenehme situation und
es hilft die temperatur im körper ein
stückchen runterzuholen dazu kühl
trinken nicht eiskalt trinken
die körperreaktion körpertemperatur und
das immunsystem wird stimuliert was
hervorragend ist aber dass paracetamol
ist natürlich wenn das viele oben bleibt
auch genommen und zwar mit augenmaß
genommen auch beim arzt abgesprochen
hervorragend wenn es eben mir ja so
schlecht geht es mich so kaputt fühle
dass ich keine kraft mehr tanken kann
dann ist es auch gut
deswegen nicht das eine gegen das andere
ausspielen das meine ich mit der welt
medizin sondern gemeinsam wir müssen
nicht die beiden schulen die
konfrontativ aufeinanderprallen sondern
beide müssen voneinander lernen die
traditionellen heilweisen anwenden
therapeuten genauso wie die schulmedizin
ich zitiere mal einen satz aus ihrem
buch zu schreiben da wieder professor am
universitätsklinikum hat auch der
kräuterkunde indianer recht wenn es ihm
mit zelebrierten zauber gelingt einen
verletzten zu heilen
ich bin mal ganz hart ist es nicht ein
bisschen ethno kitsch
ja und nein zugleich also etwa insofern
hört es sich an als als kitsch weil wir
uns keine gedanken darüber machen wir
uns keine gedanken darüber machen dass
man beispiel wenn man in einen trance
hineingerät und das machen die indianer
genauso wie ich hin halten die chinesen
knochen beispielsweise ganz vorsichtig
die gebrochen sind wieder stabilisiert
und dann das bein schämt also das gehört
ja dazu
es gehört nicht dazu wo du zu machen und
sagen jetzt ist der verletzte und das
blut bleibt stehen
nein nein da gehören ja auch ganz viele
mechanismen dazu blutstillung
beispielsweise durch kräuter hier
aufgelegt werden heilkräuter die
ausstellung beispielsweise durch
abbilden das war ja alles bekannt und
ist bekannt infektion reduzierung durch
honig den mann auf die wunde infizierte
bundes liegt also von daher muss man
weiterdenken und tiefer denken nein wo
du mit tanzen und nur stampfen und dann
meint damit würde der die wunde sich
verschließen und
der verletzte gehalten das ist wie man
das von einander unterscheiden also
wieso ist das eine hinreichend
medizinisch gut und das andere zu wenig
nur voodoo wir haben das problem in der
heutigen zeit dass wir nur das
eigentlich akzeptieren was wir natürlich
evidenzbasierte studien erforscht haben
dabei ist 80 prozent aller medikationen
aller ärztlichen tätigkeiten bis heute
überhaupt noch nicht überprüft werden
vieles aus der vergangenheit ja ist es
überprüft wenn drei ärzte mit dem hörer
ist auf die lunge hören ob alle das
gleiche hören und das richtige
daraus schließt nein also müssen wir
aufpassen wir müssen aufpassen sagen ja
es sollte alles wissenschaftlich
untersucht werden auch das was wir heute
als voodoo als bäckerei bezeichnen
sie sollte kritisch mit kritischen augen
versuchen rauszufinden was können wir
lernen genauso gut das wird diejenigen
naturkunde die sagen diese ganze
wissenschaftliche analysen des
teufelswerk brauchen wir dich ja wir
brauchen es braucht auch jeder therapeut
um rauszufinden macht das richtig oder
das falsche
also mich jetzt darum dass beide seiten
sich öffnen beide seiten genau hingucken
und dass wir genau wissenschaftlich
rausfinden was ist sinn ich das ist
unsinnig was ist quacksalberei aber
einfach nur zu behaupten geht nicht
jetzt haben sie gerade schon das
stichwort evidenzbasiert erwähnt was
tatsächlich so ein bisschen ein
zentraler begriff der medizin geworden
ist wie man genau überprüft das ein
heilmittel auch wirklich wirkt und zwar
nach wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
wirkt und wir haben eine ärztin besucht
nach telegramms die war überzeugt die
homöopathin die gehört heute zu den
vehementen kritikerinnen der natur
heilmedizin um sie verlangt genau dass
sie sagt medizinische leistungen die
müssen evidenzbasiert überprüft werden
hören wir ganz kurz zur medizin muss
wenn sie ehrlich den patienten
dargebracht wird natürlich nachweisen
können dass die aussagen die sie trifft
zum beispiel über heilungschancen
auch belegt sind sonst ist es ja ein
leeres oder ein falsches versprechen
das heißt aber nicht dass medizin nur
aus wissenschaft und evidenz und studien
besteht natürlich gehört die hype
ärztlichen heilkunst auch immer dazu
aber wenn wir den patienten sozusagen
nur mit ärztlicher heilkunst beglücken
und die ganzen wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse die werden der medizin
haben ihn runter fallen lassen
dann betreten wir ihn um einen ganz ganz
wesentlichen teil medizin ist im grunde
genommen das wissen darüber was krank
macht und was gesund macht dafür muss
medizin objektiv seien sachlich seien
messbare ergebnisse liefern wenn man in
der medizin von evidenz spricht dann
meint man damit augenscheinlich wirksam
nachweislich wirksam das heißt man hat
genügend belege gefunden dass das was
man behauptet über die methode oder über
das medikament das das wirklich stimmt
herr grönemeyer das ist wirklich stimmt
objektiv überprüfbar gibt es könnte es
uns gibt es keinen dissens dass wir das
über was wir tun sollten auch wirklich
überprüfen soll nehme ein beispiel es
gibt eine studie
eine studie mit großmaschinen öl da
wurden studenten gebeten ihre
mathematischen aufgaben zu lösen
die einen haben groß marien öl ein als
luft eingeatmet die anderen nicht es gab
keine signifikanten unterschied in der
lösung in der konzentrationsfähigkeit
der geschwindigkeit diese mathematischen
auflösen auf lösungen zu schaffen bei
denjenigen die zwischen beiden gruppen
und bei denjenigen die rosmarinöl
eingeatmet haben war es eindeutig besser
wir wissen heute dass rosmarinöl auf die
gehirnaktivität sagt wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesen wir wissen auch dass
rosmarinöl neuroprotektive ist schützt
die nerven und möglicherweise ist
rosmarinöl auch hilfreich um
vergesslichkeit ein stück weit also die
berühmte demenz im frühstadium ein
stückchen mehr zu
schützen also dass die der prozess
langsamer beispielsweise abläuft gilt
auch gibt können wir auf dem salbei und
wir wissen beispielsweise bei cystus bei
der zistrose ist eine pflanze die sieht
man in mallorca an jeder ecke ist und
kleine weiß rosa scheinende pflänzchen
was wie pergament blätter hat das wirkt
antientzündlich vor allem wenn man hals
erkrankungen hat und erkältungs
erkrankung hat cistus 0 52 gelutscht in
der apotheke auch wieder zu bekommen
hilft nachweislich nach einer studie der
charité 269 patienten die das genommen
haben dass erkältungskrankheit nicht zu
einer schweren erkrankung geworden ist
deswegen hat sie recht auf der anderen
seite hat sich auch von heilkunst
geredet das liegt natürlich noch in dem
was ich gesagt habe doch in der
aktivierung zwischen arzt und patient
über außen passiert möchte ich nachher
gleich sprechen bleiben wir ganz kurz
bei diesen unterschiedlichen formen
vielleicht über die pflanzen sprechen
dann ist es ja tatsächlich so dass die
sogenannte phytotherapie also die
therapie mit pflanzlichen mitteln die
hatten großen erfolgen es gibt ja auch
pflanzliche mittel die heute synthetisch
hergestellt werden
aspirin zum beispiel wüssten viele ja
nicht das sind eigentlich in der weiten
die verarbeitet werden dieser stoff der
ist heute steckt sozusagen aus berlin
natürlich eben nicht mehr der
synthetisch hergestellt aber ist das
gleiche chemisch gesehen wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe
aber sie gehen natürlich sehr viel
weiter in ihrem buch sie sprechen zum
beispiel über die wirkung von amuletten
das ist ja schon was anderes
ich würde mal ganz kurz auf die weide
holz zurück kommen ja es ist ein typisch
hergestellt und wenn man sich dann
andere pflanzen anguckt und auch
beispielsweise die theoretische medizin
in einem cookie ist ja
tibetische pharmafirma firma im jahr bei
zürich partner die stellen an mehr
stoffgemische herr partner 28 was bei
entzündungen aber vor allem bei der
verkalkung der gefäße und entzündung
auch von venen genommen werden kann ist
signifikant untersucht evidenz
untersucht aber sind viele verschiedene
extrakte drin wie ringelblume wie
kardamom und und anderes gekämpft da
wirkt wird es eine teil in der pflanze
verstärkt das haben wir auch in der weil
beispielsweise und nebenwirkungen
reduziert
vielleicht braucht man gerade wenn man
pflanzlich arbeit nicht so viel hat zwei
blogger nehmen in der welt weil die
pflanzen selbst schon auch noch andere
eigenschaften haben deswegen sollten wir
immer skeptisch sein wenn da
heilsversprechen geschaffen dass aspirin
ist fantastisch und das medikament von
der vero als das festgeschrieben aus als
ein notwendiges medikament der welt aber
wenn du dich leichter schmerz habe kann
ich auch mit leiden längst anfangen und
was war nochmal mit dem amulett das
amulett ist ja eigentlich wieder arzt
dann an einem anderen eine inspiration
also der arzt selbst ist ja wenn er sich
mal unter therapeutischer sich mal
selbst fragen würde als mensch ist jetzt
was von heilkunst gesagt teile ich voll
und ganz
dann hat er selbst eine heilende wirkung
habe ich zeit für den patienten rede ich
mit ihm nehme ich ihn erst das amulett
kann stellvertretend seien für irgendein
halb prozess dann verstehe ich das
richtig wenn ich sagen würde in ihrem
buch geht es einerseits um substanzen
und andererseits um dinge der heilkunst
die mit dieser beziehung zu tun haben
genau es geht um elemente die mein
gehirn aktivieren sich zu erinnern
beispielsweise auf eine eine situation
oder die mich die mich in verbindung
bringen mit einem einem gefühl der
dankbarkeit oder der des öffnens
beispielsweise gibt es ja hinweise und
chinesische medizin das
vor allen dingen ältere menschen sich
sehr genau die pflanze ankommen denn
irgendwie hoch und sie identifizieren
sich mit der pflanze auf einmal indem
sie anfangen sie zu akzeptieren das hört
sich völlig verrückt an reicht er ist
auch letztendlich aber sie sind
überzeugt dass es ihnen gut tut und dass
darum geht's jetzt also die pflanze
angucken tut mir schon gut nein das
motiviert mich jetzt nur jetzt in ingwer
beispielsweise auch zu schneiden und mir
zu nehmen also vor allem damit
identifiziert ob ich nicht so einer
pille identifizieren sie ihre im ersten
moment sei mal dahin gestellt
aber ich muss das nicht muss es annehmen
ich muss das was bekomme auch annehmen
und das läuft manchmal eben auch
durchsicht man heute ich hatte noch
keine gramm so verstanden dass sie ist
eine schwierigkeit findet wenn wir den
patienten eine palette anbieten und
diese gleichrangigkeit bestehen lassen
also sozusagen suggerieren man kann
zwiebeln ingwer medikamente weil es ist
irgendwie gleichwertig davon grenzen sie
sich immer wieder sehr deutlich ab und
sagen es gibt eindeutig situationen da
ist der notfall gefragt da muss man ins
krankenhaus war es fertig mit abwarten
und tee trinken
aber es gibt trotzdem oder das wäre eine
frage er am sie ist es nicht auch eine
schwierigkeit für mich die ich nicht so
viel verstehe von medizin wenn ich so
ein buch lesen waren wirklich
unterscheiden zu können sie schreiben zb
weihrauch hätte eine heilende wirkungen
könnt ihr auch tumorzellen daran hindern
weiter zu wachsen kann es nicht
passieren dass krebspatienten denken ich
noch nicht die chemo ich mache das nicht
gemein
das ist hochgefährlich und das da grenzt
du mich massiv gegen hab leider war auch
beispielsweise das machen wir auch geben
wir zum beispiel um schwellung zu
reduzieren und das einfach es nützt ja
auch deswegen glaube ich auch dass der
dass der und es wirkt antientzündlich
dass deswegen ist ja wohl auch eines der
ältesten überhaupt medikamente der welt
ja es ist anti effects und weihrauch
wurden mumien so desinfiziert damit sie
auch bis heute unter anderem dass sie
bis heute einfach noch so erhalten
geblieben sind wie sie sind einfach hat
unterschiedliche wirkung eben auch die
abschwellende wirkung und man kriegt
weiter auch ja eben auch als als kleines
haar zu kügelchen was man was heute eben
auch von der tour erkundigten firmen
dann anders verarbeitet werden ja dort
gegeben wird ich bin ein fan der
individuelle therapie ich sage nicht
jede grippe läuft bei jedem gleich jeder
hat unterschiedliche symptome jeder ist
im anderen stadium die daten
unterschiedliches immunsystem
deswegen muss ich jeden menschen anders
behandeln der eine kann die riten die
zwiebel nicht riechen beispielsweise der
dritte markt knoblauch überhaupt nicht
als wunderbares und ein bisschen auch
blutdrucksenkende gewürzt ein bisschen
auch nahrungs verdauen förder förderndes
element wieder irgendwer beispielsweise
auch und der dritte brauchen eine an das
andere dosis und der vierte brauchen die
kombination zwischen allen also ist das
eine eine frage der ärztlichen kunst der
heilkunst der therapeutischen und auch
von der nichtärztlichen therapeuten
angewandt was man wann und wie sind die
menschen wirklich so unterschiedlich
heute sagt man ja mit big data können
eigentlich relativ genaue prognosen
gemacht werden wenn jemand zum beispiel
an krebs erkrankt ist den todeszeitpunkt
schon wochen vorher vorherzusagen weil
man einfach so viele daten hat und die
menschen eben doch nicht so
unterschiedlich sind
keiner von uns kann sagen und er stirbt
wir können das auch nicht voraussagen
ich halte das für für einen gott
ähnlichen zustand
da möglicherweise ein gesamtes system
hinein rutscht was für mich total in
oman ist keiner kann es und wenn man
heute prozesse auch in der mit diktator
vorausschauend nutzen kann da geht es
darum eigentlich mehr welches welcher
extrakt welches spezifische einzel
substrat kann eigentlich auf eine
bestimmte situation im körper beim
individuellen patienten werden
das ist gut das finde ich spannend und
das finde ich gut wenn ich weiß also das
ist eigentlich dieses antibiotika
antibiotikum wirkt jetzt ganz genau in
dieser erkrankung hervorragend in der
chemotherapie natur therapie genauso
habe den tod meines bruders
vorauszuschauen für den ich alles getan
habe der mann gestorben ist ja der
schulmedizinisch naturheilkundlich auch
behandelt wurde
bis hin zur stammzelltransplantation das
vorauszusagen dass das hilft nein das
ich habe man sich schließlich an
leukämie
ja und da ist nicht weggehen noch am tag
in der nacht an dem tag vorher gewarnt
nach zurückgeflogen nach berlin also der
stabilität aber dann gestorben ist da
war er putzmunter
da waren putzmunter und hat gesagt ich
weiß gar nicht wenn ich jetzt weiter
lebe was ich habe alles gegeben 44 muss
man leben ganz neu organisieren herr
hoffnungsfroh das mache ich gehe raus
und kaum war ich raus ist ja haben
meines vaters gestorben
also hatte selbst das gekriegt und es
hat er noch intensivstation gelegen eine
zeit und nahm das ist das wissen wir
halt nicht und das ist auch gut so
wir müssen für das leben kämpfen ich bin
tot wenn man sagt ich kann es voraus
tage vorher monate voraus schauen ist
doch quatsch es gibt so viele beispiele
wo menschen den tumor auch
bauchspeicheldrüsen tumor unsere
überwunden haben mit entsprechender erst
schulmedizin und dann selbst noch mit
ihrer eigenen kraft
hat sie der tod ihres bruders auch
verändert aus arzt ja ich hatte auch
eine leichte haltung wir können das so
wir als ärzte haben ja so immer wieder
herrlich kommt man so ein punkt für
schwere und das wird uns ja auch mit
gegeben im studium wir können eigentlich
alles ja wir haben uns fehlt manchmal
die die kritische reflexion auch zum tod
und auch zu den selbstheilungskräften
des einzelnen und wenn ich das gut
wirken seelen sehe ich dass ich im tode
meines bruders verstanden habe wir
entscheiden nicht wann wir auf dieser
welt kommen entscheidend wohin wir gehen
wir wissen auch gar nicht wohin wir
gehen ja das wissen wir nicht aber es
ist so toll zu leben und fürs leben zu
kämpfen und diese kurze zeit auch im
wissen dass wir nie wieder kommen
es ist dann wäre es anders und bange was
wir nicht wiederkommt aber das macht
demütig und das macht demütig auch vor
der existenz vor dem kosmos voller vor
dem schöpfer den unterschiede kulturen
eben anders nennen oder auch monate ist
sieht das genauso ja ich wollte ja nur
anders formuliert wenn das habe ich
begriffen und das hat mich unheimlich
unheimlich offen werden lassen
stark werden lassen aber auch zu sagen
mensch ich muss den einzelnen da abholen
wo er ist mein bruder hat sich anders
verhalten als wiederum andere und das
ist diese vielfalt des lebens der
medizin die so spannend ist und so bis
zu begeistern das ist auch was sie
erzählen ist eigentlich gar nicht so
unähnlich wie das was ihr anderer bruder
erzählt hat herbert grönemeyer der
rocksänger der hat ja in derselben woche
die ihr bruder gestorben ist der wilhelm
grüne meyer auch noch seine frau
verloren und ich habe mich mit ihnen
darüber unterhalten
also erstmal das natürlich
die ultimative katastrophe gleichzeitig
war so so so so überdimensional dass man
eher der engländer sagen wir warten am
mann war
man fühlte sich nicht mehr und umgekehrt
kriegt man sich eine größere demuth vom
leben und erkennt aber dann auch wieder
natürlich auch diese unfassbare
schönheit des lebens weil man eben
miterleben musste oder was passiert was
menschen dazu stößt was mit menschen
passiert welches leid erfahren und das
ist relativiert natürlich wieder vieles
ich glaube es das leben wird wird jeder
beziehung es gibt eine farbe die man
vorher nicht hatte
die läuft mit die bleibt auch da bleibt
immer vorhanden ist ein farbton den
hatte mal in seiner wenn der mensch
durch so ein farbschema ich glaube jeder
mit strahlt auch er ist ein ganz ruhiges
wesen und da plötzlich addiert sich eine
farbe die war vorher nicht da zum glück
hat das ist das leben so geschaffen dass
die anderen farben aber irgendwann auch
wieder an farbe gewinnen und dann ist
die daten bleibt diese farbe da aber
überdeckt nicht alles andere aber es ist
eine neue ist einen neuen ersten mann an
um ihm bleibt vorhanden aber die läuft
immer mit allem mit und gleichzeitig ist
es aber glaube ich auch so dass auch
eine essenz des lebens weil es ändert
sich auch die endlichkeit natürlich ganz
klar vor augen hält die endlichkeit vor
augen hält das war ungefähr das was sie
vorhin auch selber gesagt hat hat es da
und dieses ich betone es einfach noch
mal diese schönheit und diese
dankbarkeit leben zu dürfen
ja da sein zu dürfen auch wenn es noch
so widrig ist auch der heutigen zeit und
wir auch verluste erleben wie einfluss
meiner meines bruders herbert haller
frau und andere menschen mehr trotzdem
ist das leben was
das sagt ja die salutogenese die
salutogenese dessen anhänger ich bin im
gegensatz zur pathogenese also das
gesund die die ja das wissen und die
lehre von dem gesund bleiben im
gegensatz von dem der krankheit die das
ist nicht gesund bleiben ja und dieser
salutogenese sagt ja dass ich wichtig
ist sich selbst zu erkennen den sinn des
lebens versucht zu begreifen und das
leben als ganzes anzunehmen und sagt
weiterhin es gibt immer einen zustand
zwischen gesund und krank hat man nie
das ist ein ganz großer gelehrter
jüdischer wissenschaftler des
mittelalters eigentlich ein der
wahrscheinlich auch schon gesagt es gibt
immer diese übergänge zwischen gesund
und krank und dazwischen gibt es den
neutralen bereich so sagt kallen ist an
unser alter urvater der medizin aber man
ist eben auch so wie dieser route genese
eigentlich formulierte gesagt mensch das
licht dort mit an dir wie du die
schnellste im leben und dieses leben ist
so ein tolles was toll ist dass wir
immer wieder vergessen jeden tag und bei
der ganzen komplexität des heutigen zeit
hätten wir uns gar nicht mehr und man
merkt sehr stark in ihnen sitzt dieser
arzt es sitzt vielleicht auch noch so
etwas mit drin wie das sie mal den
wunsch hatten pastor zu werden also es
gibt auch so der heiler in ihnen der
wirklich interessiert ist eben an diesen
ganzheitlichen verständnis wird gerne
noch ein bisschen mehr verstehen was
eigentlich ganzheitlichkeit heißt was
ist diese ganzheitliche medizin was
meinen sie damit genau er steht ja auf
dem weg zu einer ganzheitlichen
heilkunst
für mich ist
eigentlich von kindheit an eigentlich
das leben unter menschen das leben mit
menschen das gefühl vom vom du zum wir
auf dich zum duzen wir eigentlich eine
ganz wesentliches element dafür muss ich
mich aber kennen lernt dazu muss ich
mich auch lernen zu leben weil dann kann
ich in dieser kraft auf dem anderen
gutes tun also hilft dem anderen auch
dann reflektiert sich das auch wieder zu
der und helfen heißt eigentlich offen
sein
was wenn der medizin lernen müssen jetzt
wieder zu hören nicht den patienten
sofort unterbrach und erbrechen in
deutschland ist ein patient nach zwei
minuten wieder aus vom arzt aus dem
gespräch heraus da 18 sekunden wird er
unterbrochen sind alle statistiken das
robert koch institut ist mit anderen
einrichtungen und 30 minuten aus der
praxis weiß gar nicht was er hat und
welches medikament bekommt und wie es
wirkt so ich will das aber wissen und
ganzheitlichkeit heißt für mich damit
auch mich in meinem denken und fühlen
wohlfühlen körperlich wohl fühlen mit
anderen menschen und auf dieser erde
wohl fühlen also auch in verbindung zu
den tieren ist man immer mensch nach dem
hunde und katzen und ihr herz geht auf
und sie sind die besten begleiter auch
wir hätten in schweren situationen
wir stellen uns blumen auf den tisch wir
versuchen wieder auch ein bisschen
bewusster zu essen und auch schön zuerst
das ist alles ganzheitlichkeit die ich
so wichtig finde um selbst wohlbefinden
zwar jetzt haben wir sowohl über den
arzt die über den patienten gesprochen
wenn wir von ganzheitlichkeit sprechen
bei mir mal kurz beim patienten sie
kritisieren im buch ja auch dass viele
menschen reflexartig ganz vieles
abweisen oder zurückweisen das betrifft
ihre kollegen und kolleginnen
schulmediziner die sagen was soll das
mit dem ingwer oder der zwiebeln wickel
vergessen sie es einfach aber es
betrifft hat auch die patienten also
diese idee abwarten und tee trinken was
ja vielleicht mal ein kluges rezept auch
sein
das ist ja nichts wofür die patienten
noch zeit haben
ich habe gerade wunderbaren wäre wenn er
getrunken hier bei ihm
ich war ja ist ja das ja hier zu hause
ist also nt den franzosen beispielsweise
abends sagt ich gerne anbieten immer um
ereignisse bereichen kraut ist also um
ein stück weit und dazu kommen egal ob
die evidenzbasierte medizin das jetzt
beschreiben würde er nicht es ist ein
wunderbares mittel um ruhe zu finden ist
doch toll den kritikern halte ich
letztendlich auf beiden seiten vor das
sieht dass sie zu schnell sind
da ist aber auch das system schuld weil
das system häufig eins zu eins auch in
deutschland bestimmte prozesse rein
zwängt sodass weg zum teil gar keine
zeit mehr haben für den patienten ja
weil es nicht bezahlt wird
beispielsweise bei uns in deutschland es
ist aber auf der anderen seite eben auch
die selbstüberschätzung teilweise der
methoden ja das gilt für den natur-
konter zum teil genauso wie für den für
den schulmediziner und ich für den
patienten sage ich heute er braucht halt
ich beides wir brauchen zugang und jetzt
empfehle ich auch such dir einen guten
arzt oder ärzten des vertrauens das kann
der hausarzt kann aber die gynäkologin
genauso sein oder der chefarzt einer
klinik weil der spricht weil meine
sprache versteht mich erkennt meine
geschichte und ein natur konter und dann
könnten wir eigentlich die welten
zunehmend wieder zusammenbringen und
verstehen dass wir ja von ganz dahinten
kommen bekommen ja aus 10.000 jahren der
menschheits bewussten
menschheitsgeschichte im moment zum
heute also zurück in die zukunft ist für
mich ein wesentliches element
ich sage ja auch dass viele
naturheilkundliche verfahren von
schamanen von hexen zb ausgerottet
worden sind zum teil auch aus
politischen gründen weil man nicht
wahrhaben wollten was die firmen wissen
bewahren was halten sie von der these
dass gewisse dinge auch
ausgerottet wurden oder sich überlebt
haben dann einfach rausgefunden hat es
bringt nichts also wenn man blinddarm
hat dann ist es doch besser das ding
raus zu schnippeln abzuwarten und tee
trinken oder ups zu kriegen oder eine
vereiterung weil er blind dann
durchbricht natürlich das ist doch auch
dass das tolle der hochzeit ich mein ich
weiß gar nicht wie ich kann mir auch
nicht vorstellen wie man früher zähne
gezogen hat die wir nicht wissen das ist
ja auf der anderen seite haben wir auch
schon im babylonischen zur biologischen
zeiten bei den ägyptern weil ein paar
samen mit kleinsten instrumenten im auge
operiert die instrumente wenn man sich
sicher heute anguckt sind nicht
unterschiedlich die sind nur heute viel
feind viel kleiner
die bürger bezahlen nicht aber für und
für das fürs auge und für die
gehirnoperationen natürlich auch aber es
ist viele star oder nehmen wir die
akupunktur wir haben haben chinesen
früher mit akupunkturnadeln nerven
stimuliert und da drauf und beifuß
häubchen gesetzt und es angezündet
es ist also ganz schrecklich recht mag
es nicht mag dem gebot nicht so aber sie
haben die nager erhitzt um den nerven
unten zu stimulieren heute nehmen wir
elektrische stimulation des hochfrequenz
ablation und veröden so ein nerven mache
ich tatsächlich auch bei uns in der
mikro tafel gibt auch dinge die sie klar
zurückweisen
also sie plädieren ja für so eine
gleichrangigkeit all dieser methoden
gibt dinge wo sie sagen nein das ist
jetzt wirklich scharlatanerie damit
möchte ich nichts zu tun haben wo sie
reflexartig nein sagen ja allerlei
versprechungen beispielsweise weil ein
tumor kranken zu heilen weil ich den mit
irgendwelchen nicht irgendwelchen
sonstigen methoden verführe denke da an
jemanden aus meinem
bei freunden freundeskreis der die
prostata operation abgelehnt hat beim
krebs und aprikosen gerne genommen hatte
reich weil er darin einen aprikosen kern
kann ein mittel sein soll was eben ein
zellgift ist und wird gesagt das hilft
mir der ist landet direkt elendig
verreckt das war seine entscheidung ich
kann ich mir auch nicht abnehmen der
menschen aber ich sage das ist das ist
menschenverachtend
diese menschenverachtend und geht zurich
und verstehe ich sie richtig dass sie
jetzt sagen es geht nicht darum dass wir
das therapeutikum also die eher dass das
aprikosen kernöl ablehnen sondern es
geht darum dass wir in dieser situation
etwas anderes tun sollten zu machen sie
lehnen reflexartig keine medizin keine
heilkunst ab sondern immer nur in einer
bestimmten situation würden sie sagen
dass ich jetzt nicht das mittel der wahl
ich wüsste keinen anderen wissen wo man
kann an anwendungsmöglichkeiten den
aprikosen kern also deswegen sage ich
das lehne ich ab
ja so ja in dieser form aber trotzdem
bleibe ich kritisch sein wenn man
darüber nachdenkt und guckt was warum
ist das eigentlich mal verschrieben
wollen die welchen büchern stand haas
macht man das auch hildegard von bingen
beispielsweise ja da ist ja
wahrscheinlich die mutter der naturkunde
in den europäischen kontext sicherlich
fantastische ärzten und theologen und
teilen gewesen trotzdem kritisch sein
das sind 1800 rezepte beschrieben weil
er im letzten jahrhundert wieder
herausgearbeitet vieles ist nicht
überprüft vieles ist auch möglicherweise
hat starker nebenwirkungen also
vorsichtig bin vorsichtig ja trotzdem
öffne ich mich und sage da muss man
wissenschaftlich an evidenzbasiert haben
denn wird die globuli
es gibt eine heftigste diskussionen und
da hört ja auch die ärztin sicherlich
ist ja auch noch dazu dass man
tatsächlich nicht formuliert vermutlich
aber dieses skeptisch ich bin der
meinung es muss wissenschaftlich
überprüft werden wir sollten aber
trotzdem sehen dass es genügend
beispiele gibt aus der praxis
die praxis der welt wo um die
homöopathie
hilfreich ist auch bei tieren sollte man
nach gucken warum nicht einfach sagen
ich interessant herr grönemeyer weil sie
jetzt das so betonen wir sollten das
wissenschaftlich überprüfen
es gibt ja unterschiedliche arten über
versöhnung zu sprechen über versöhnung
von traditionen die einen würden
wahrscheinlich so wie sie sagen lasst
uns alles mal ausprobieren nicht
reflexartig zurückweisen aber schon
überprüfen
die anderen würden vielleicht sagen wir
sprechen von ganz unterschiedlichen
menschen bildern
wenn jemand ein menschenbild hat der
mensch ist ein lichtwesen sag ich jetzt
mal oder der mensch ist ein kraftfeld
dann ist dieses menschenbild vielleicht
gar nicht versöhnt mit dem menschenbild
was der schulmedizin zu grunde liegt ja
es sind unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen sind auch
unterschiedliche reflektionen weil der
schulmedizin nicht eigentlich nur der
körper zu grunde und die körper
orientierung und wir sind natürlich auf
dem fähig indigene und in den in den
versuchen zusammenhänge zu zu finden die
wir heute noch gar nicht formulieren
kann die jene sind so viel wie das
sandkorn hier in der wand im zement und
wir wissen gar nicht wie diese mauer
eigentlich hält also sind erst die
ersten komponenten und wir glauben aber
jetzt schon die personifizierte medizin
formuliert zu haben ich sagte er an
derjenige der ein wirkliches weltbild
hat der psychosomatisch denkt der den
menschen als körper geist versteht der
wo beides zusammen gespielt weil ich
kann jeden moment nicht selbst wieder
entspannen oder kraft tanken oder anders
essen und bin motiviert klaffen
auseinander trotzdem haben sie eines
gemeinsam sie wollen beide heilen und
ich glaube wenn man da den gemeinsamen
nenner versucht herauszufinden und
versucht herauszufinden warum
ist die schulmedizin so so kompakt auf
den körper warum blendet sie und dass
ich halte das für ein fehler der
aufklärung weil wir unter descartes
eigentlich als maschine definiert worden
sind das sind wirklich ein fehler
wir müssen die geisteswissenschaften
wieder dazu nehmen und dann nähern wir
uns auf einmal auch wieder denjenigen
die ein anderes weltbild und
menschenbild haben an ob das jetzt ob
ich das verstehe oder nicht sei mal erst
mal dahin gestellt aber und ob ich das
gut finde ja auch aber ich nähere mich
an und kann dann die diskussion führen
und die muss geisteswissenschaftlich
auch geführt werden und nicht nur
naturwissenschaftlich es ist ja so dass
es auch in vielen universitäten
mittlerweile lehrstühle gibt für
komplementärmedizin in der schweiz
gezogen entsprechendes gesetz das
vorschreibt dass entsprechende kurse
auch angeboten werden müssen und den
medizinischen fakultäten aber natalie
gress diese kritikerin die sagt diese
these dass die medizin eigentlich
defizitär sei die ist an sich eigentlich
schon problematisch ich würde er gerne
noch mal ganz kurz mit ihm zu werden
herr professor grönemeyer tritt ja an
und sagt ich möchte die
alternativmedizin und andere exotische
ansätze mit der schulmedizin versöhnen
ich glaube aber dass der graben noch
tiefer getreten wird weil menschen der
medizin weniger vertrauen aber eben auch
wegen büchern wie diesen weil dort so
getan wird als wäre die medizin
schrecklich defizitär es würde dort ganz
vieles fehlen sie würde sich gegenüber
allem exotischen oder irgendwie anders
artigen verschließen und ihre
medikamente hätte nur nebenwirkungen es
ging nur um profit und es ging nicht
mehr um gesundheit und ich finde solche
bücher tragen dazu bei dieses vorurteil
zu zementieren
das halte ich für ein gerücht und möchte
auch ganz klar mich dagegen verwehren
weil ich genau das gegenteil ist der
fall
das probiere ich auch in meinem buch
also ich halte die schulmedizin für ein
wesentliches fundament in das andere
ansätze der medizin auch integriert
werden und dass wir
und ich verharmlose überhaupt nicht
nebenwirkungen und und weiß ja auch
daraufhin ganz konkret das ist und dass
sich das als als formulierung der der
industrie formuliert habe das überhaupt
nicht lebensbuch steht das bei mir das
hat irgendjemand anders vielleicht
irgendwo formuliert oder sind im kopf
aber scheinbar das buch nicht in ruhe
durchgelesen aber eine these glaube ich
dich beschäftigt ist die frage wie wir
eigentlich auf die medizin blicken wie
viele defizite gibt es da wirklich und
wie sehr geben wir den patienten das
gefühl
guck mal da musste ich echt noch
umgucken weil die medizin am sich die
dect überhaupt nicht das ab was
eigentlich gut ist für dich und da
könnte es ja auch zu einer schwierigkeit
kommen bezüglich des sogenannten selbst
bestimmten patienten der für sich selber
eine wahl treffen muss was er denn jetzt
aus der ganzen palette auswählen soll
das ich mache ich ja
gesundheitsunterricht ballkindern
brauchen ein buch mitgenommen wir besser
es lang geht es um ernährung mehr noch
aber das hat ja auch was soll ich mit
kindern geschrieben
die kinder geschrieben und die kinder ja
auch gefragt werden die studie gemacht
weil 8000 schulkindern dann mit der
firma deichmann zusammen haben sie
gefragt was ist für euch
das heißt für euch gesund hatte eine
gesagt ernährung deswegen besser ist
genau wissen was das ist
das ist bewegung aktiv sein und
eigenverantwortlich wohlbefinden
bekommen weil ich das was wir alle aber
jeder mensch in der welt eigentlich weiß
und auch fühlt ist kann er stark sich
für das schwach fühlte er sich bewegt
kann sie stark oder schwach höhen wir
wissen noch nicht viel mehr die körper
das körperbewusstsein ist ja viel
stärker da als als wir es heute der
heutigen zeit wahrnehmen und
gleichzeitig sollte man eben die bildung
verstärken damit wir einen einen
patienten und patientinnen bekommen der
viel aufgeklärter ist deswegen schreibe
ich mir meine bücher schreibe meine
bücher und mehr aufklärung zu schaffen
ob es das rücken buch ist ob das herz
buch ist
mein haus buch der gesundheit wo man
nachschlagen kann und auch motiviert
wird das auch noch 20 jahre bestimmt
stimmt weil weil auch dort das
evidenzbasierte medizin ganz klar für
jede erkrankung bis auf krebs und kinder
erkrankung runter dekliniert und wenn
der aufgeklärte patienten gegenüber
sitzt dann haben wir nicht und das wird
ja viel auf die augen hört das muss
gespräch haben da muss ich mir zeit
nehmen da muss weg durchs gespräch
vertrauen und dann kann ich ausländer
nehmen die zwiebel den irgendwie oder
das aspirin scharf drauf gepackt sind ja
dass der patient schafft das wenn ich
ihm helfen dass ich das im gespräch auch
zu motivieren selbst mit verantwortung
zu übernehmen und deswegen sage ich auch
noch einen naturheilkundlich
ausgebildeten arzt ich meine es gibt die
lehrstühle an den universitäten gibt es
in der schweiz haben wir in deutschland
da sind tolle leute mittlerweile die
einfach genau da forschen deswegen kann
ich sehr programms nur sagen also
vorsichtig in der argumentation weil du
zementiert ist jetzt die schulmedizin
ist genau das was ich nicht will
ja ich will aber auch nicht dass die
traditionellen heilweisen sich so
zementieren sondern ich will das fenster
öffnen und das mit in mit
wissenschaftlicher methodik sprechen wir
noch einmal über dieses gespräch das sie
in unserem herzen liegt das eben auch
die rolle des arztes aus heiler als
berater aus umfassender begleiter sie
präsentieren auch sehr stark für gut
ausgebildete hausärzte in diesem
zusammenhang wenn man die zukunft blickt
dann sagen viele dass wird sich sowieso
fundamental ändern die leute werden da
ihre selbst trekkingtouren haben die
werden ihre apps haben
und das führt dazu dass daten basiert
wir sehr schnell sehr viele diagnosen
sehr viel einfacher computergestützt big
data gestützt stellen können und dann
gibt es plötzlich wieder raum für das
arzt-patienten-verhältnis für das
gespräch der arzt wird mehr zum coach
andere sagen das ist humbug es hier eine
andere richtung gehen wir werden nämlich
den arzt in zukunft noch vor
bildschirmen sehen der typ teiligen
lassen seinen bildschirm rein
währenddessen der patient verloren
daneben sitzt
was glauben sie in welche richtung geht
vertrauen sie da den möglichkeiten
lokalisierung also gut begleitete
information zu bekommen auch ihre
trecker halte ich für sinnvoll wenn es
erst lich therapeutisch begleitet wird
ja wir haben 100 prozentig heute schon
viele hypochonder erzeugt durch diese
techniken geben zu wenig zu sehr auf das
klo an das glauben was da auf der uhr
steht anstatt zu wissen wirklich damit
umzugehen das ding ist der
sportphysiologe der sporttrainer der
physiologe der wer auch immer der der
arzt der haushalte heilpraktiker der
trainer immer auch so wichtig um damit
daten umzugehen aber vor allem der arzt
des vertrauens das wird in zukunft die
medizin sicherlich verändern und
optimieren den alltag des praktischen
arztes oder auch krankenhausarztes gute
möglichkeiten geben einfach auch
verläufe auch den prozess einer
erkrankung oder eines gesunderhaltung
des prozesses zu dürfen zu beobachten
und dazu führen auf der anderen seite
glaube ich dass die technik mehr
abnehmen wird auch in der radiologie
werden mehr künstliche intelligenz haben
die uns schon sagen was könnte das für
und im computer kernspin oder münchen
oder ultraschallbild sein
wir stehen dann vor der entscheidung zu
sagen das könnte stimmen würde passt
überein mit den symptomen des patienten
das ist hilfreich ich glaube dass
dadurch der patient entlastet wird und
viel mehr ins gespräch gehen kann
vielmehr sich gedanken machen kann zur
prävention wie kann ich gesund erhalten
darum geht es ja letztendlich sollte es
so bleiben die chinesen haben früher
angeblich herz nur bezahlt wenn sie
krankheiten verhindert haben und ich
wenn sie behandelt haben unter der
patient wird sich mehr um sich also
körper geist und körper und einbindung
in soziale körper geist und einbindung
in soziale gedanken machen mehr
seelsorgerisch auch tätig sein und dann
vorbeugend vielleicht viel mehr in den
bereich sportmedizin in vielmehr im
bereich der der naturheilkundlichen
anwendungen in der ernährung
der ernährung ist irgendwie ist ein
gewürz zwiebel ist ein gewürz wir
verhindern damit dass gleichzeitig allen
mitteln verhindern damit erkrankung um
das ist genau auch ein wichtiger teil
sie sprechen immer wieder eben auch über
prävention haben sie jetzt auch gerade
getan es gibt auch ein lustiger ein
lustiges rezept turne bis zur urne also
das turnen ist ihnen auch sehr wichtig
bezogen auf den auf die spitze getrieben
gesagt nichts hilft bei der genesung so
sehr wie regelmäßige arztrechnung wenn
man die patienten wenn man die patienten
nicht schlau macht dann sind sie
natürlich interessiert schnell die pin
zu kriegen es geht ihm nicht gut in dem
moment sie wollen dass er arzt was tut
und das system bezahlt das ja auch die
wollen das ja auch aber das ist nicht
die richtige herangehensweise weil man
schaltet sich selbst ab welche rechnung
wenn ich dann zum arzt gehen und meine
der hilft mir dann für entmündige ich
mich ja letztendlich ja aber ich kann
mit vielen mittelmeer auch selbst helfen
ich sag mal ein beispiel ich habe
unheimlich viele patienten die
psychosomatisch als rückenspezialist den
bandscheiben ambulant operiert der
schmerzen an der bande an der
wirbelsäule nimmt und die haben einfach
druck zu hause weiß ich jetzt hat jahren
den mann oder der mann die frau pflegen
die kompletten alltag berufsalltag nicht
zurecht die muss sich nicht behandeln
dann schicke ich häufig zurück und sagt
macht sport nicht passieren
ja und sie zu ich helfe dir auch mit
bestimmten spannungs übungen ja da
brauche ich nicht die rechnung vom arzt
damit es mir besser geht wenn ich jetzt
mal so alex kindes übersetzte auf der
anderen seite ist es natürlich auch
unterscheidet sich natürlich auch damit
ich glaube der meinte natürlich mir noch
so was wie wenn sie etwas kostet dann
strenge ich mich auch an gesund zu
werden
ich glaube ich habe noch eine andere
idee dahinter
lassen sie mich noch ein thema
ansprechen denn wir über ganzheitliche
medizin sprechen dann interessiert mich
auch noch ein anderes thema was bei
ihnen gar nicht so vorkommt aber
letztlich eine große geschichte in der
nzz am sonntag der bikini blick in der
medizin und da geht es darum dass die
medizin sehr stark eigentlich die
schulmedizin auf die männer fokussiert
das heißt die norm ist der männliche
körper die probanden sind meistens
männer weil man angst hat auch die
hormonschwankungen der frau die
studienresultate verfälschen könnten
man darf auch weniger studien mit frauen
machen weil man nicht weiß ob sie
schwanger werden könnten und insgesamt
gibt es viele krankheiten die weniger
erforscht sind die zu einem höheren
prozentsatz frauen betreffen würden oder
ob es noch andere auch andere symptome
über herzinfarkt hatte man hier sagen
dass schmerzen die frau hat
bauchschmerzen häufig weltweit gesehen
auch so wenn sie sagen ganzheitliche
heilkunst könnte man ja auch jetzt nicht
nur ganze zeit nicht so verstehen dass
wir alle kulturen mit beziehen bzw
sondern eben auch alle menschen sprich
auch die kinder auch die frauen ja jeder
muss unterschiedliche kinder müssen ganz
unterschiedlich untersucht werden die
frauen und männer weil alle und auch
alte leute alle haben ganz
unterschiedlich stoffwechsel an
alle haben ganz andere genetische
voraussetzungen und da machen wir eine
din a4 situation untersuchung eigentlich
ein studien beispielsweise vermehrt
männer und kriegen gleich ergebnisse die
im grunde aufs kind nicht mehr
anzuwenden sind auf den alten menschen
auch also von daher muss ich forschung
hundertprozentig an der stelle maximal
ändern haben sie auf ihren vielen vielen
reisen die sie gemacht haben die alle
vorkommen hier drin also bhutan sri
lanka auf lateinamerika sie waren sehr
sehr vielen orten unterwegs denn auch
dinge gefunden von dem sie gedacht haben
das ist jetzt so richtig erstaunlich
oder erschüttern damit hätten sie nie
gerechnet
ich war jetzt lang gehabt wollte mich
immer neuen chinesischen wissen weiter
weiter ausbilden und bin auch radiologe
geworden weil ich viele akupunktur
früher schon dem ende des studiums mir
beigebracht habe oder nicht mir
beigebracht wurde von inhouse
bildungszentren habe vor dem studium ja
auch chinesisch studiert theologie
studiert und kommen nach sri lanka und
sehe eine ärztin von der schlagen wollte
wie sich einfach kinder behandelt hat
mit mit akupunktur mit massagen und ich
hab dann eben gesehen wie überwältigt
der eltern auf einmal so freudig waren
weil die kinder auf einmal keine spastik
mehr hatten
weil dort die chinesische medizin mit
massagen mit akupunktur mit anderen
herangehensweise einfach geholfen haben
das hat mich das hat mir kolossal gut
getan weil das mein leben letztendlich
geprägt hat weil ich gesagt habe wir
sollten auch dinge verstehen wollen die
auf den ersten blick merkwürdig
erscheinen
ich glaube wenn ich jetzt zurückblicke
auch auf unser gespräch sie haben einen
sehr umfassenden begriff von heilung und
wahrscheinlich suchen menschen ja auch
nach einer umfassenden heilung wenn wir
sehen wie sehr mein vorne es kurse
blumen wie viele menschen meditieren wie
viele menschen sich verschiedenen formen
der spiritualität zu wenden der mensch
sucht noch nach anderen dingen wie
alleine der organismus der funktioniert
würden sie sagen alle diese dimension
möchten sie selber auch abdecken oder
gibt es dinge sagen sie dann naja darauf
ich dann doch wieder den fahrer sein
erstes gar nicht so persönlich und
keiner von uns in der hinterhand
in der vielfalt das hatte ich über
blicken also mein plädoyer ist erst
einen therapeuten aller couleur im team
sind wir für den patienten da so
deswegen müssen wir auch zusammen die
welt weiter entwickeln die medizin ist
neben essen und trinken das älteste
kulturgut das gilt es zu erhalten und
weiterzuentwickeln
und wenn s
wenn ich einen schweren situationen bin
oder wenn ich auch am ende meines lebens
bin oder wenn ich jemanden verloren habe
dann brauche ich noch sonder
seelsorgerische haltung nicht umsonst
haben und dorthin ist auch galli galli
100 jahre nach christi geburt gegangen
nach ägypten der hohen kultur der
medizin
da gab es das asklepios priester und
erste haben zusammen gearbeitet und ich
glaube das ist auch nation ist haben wir
längst vergessen und verloren da sollten
wir wieder hinkommen
in der offenheit füreinander
ich danke ihnen sehr man sagt immer das
gespräch ist die beste medizin insofern
vielen herzlichen dank für die medizin
und ich frage sie jetzt nicht nach der
diagnose danke sehr
nächste woche geht es vom organismus zum
orgasmus wolfram eilenberger geht mit
seinen gästen den besonderen höhepunkt
des menschlichen daseins auf den grund
[Musik]